what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren and today i have with me chris
for um episode like five
six podcast i'm not gonna keep track
next episode of the podcast um today
we're gonna be talking about
a very important topic it's a topic or
it's a question that a lot of people
have been asking lately it's a big
debate online and that is
is marvel
kind of blowing it right now with the
mcu is marvel blowing it with phase four
and phase five or
is it really great
a lot of people complained recently you
know
hey i'm not really liking phase four so
far i don't like the disney plus shows
they're not as good i didn't like some
of the movies they're not as good as
well
um what are your initial thoughts on it
chris do you think phase four is going
well do you think phase five is going to
get better
initial thoughts about all of this
debate that's been going around online
you know what's funny the question is
posed is marvel blowing it and all i
could think is when you're saying that
is like the average youtuber thumbnail
face like
like there is so much
theatrics
and outside influence on what's
happening at marvel and i think they're
having a genuine struggle or we as fans
are having a genuine struggle deciding
where we land
i feel like every day we talk to fans
and we have these these conversations
about is marvel doing a good job and
sometimes people are like
yeah no i've loved every project and
then they're quickly swayed by different
youtubers and communities and tick
tockers they're like oh wait no actually
it's bad
there is this huge social media problem
right
yeah so i think it's hard to say oh
we've gotten we've gone through phase
four where are we as as marvel
because the majority
doesn't know where they stand
yeah and i think and i want to state
right away you should definitely form
your own opinion even after you watch
this video no
podcast
don't just tell me what to think
no form your own
if you disagree with me fine we can
disagree and be friendly no big deal but
let's talk about this like are they
blowing it i don't think they're blowing
it
i don't think so i i think there's i
think there's a problem that comes with
disney plus
because one thing we're going to talk
about is patience
i feel like the people who don't like
phase 4 right now
kind of are getting impatient because
they're expecting a lot of really big
things to happen in which we haven't
really
gotten those yet right so the disney
plus shows let's talk about what those
are those are these are new
first of all right and people are
comparing them to avengers infinity war
and it's like of course they're not
[Laughter]
of course you're let down right no
wonder you don't like them you can't
compare them to the two biggest films
the cinema of like all time it's yeah
right let's say not just marvel like in
cinema you can't compare them because
kevin feige said these are origin
stories and disney plus allows them to
take their time
and introduce them tell the origin story
and then he said and then they'll come
together on the big screen
and team up with other people from other
disney plus shows and movies so it's
patience and i know a lot of people
don't like hearing that nobody ever
likes to yeah patience is a fun thing
right exactly but it's a rewarding thing
it is right because like
although you know the infinity saga was
great we didn't have to wait a long time
and you know we had to wait 10 years
until everything came together we're in
year well you know pandemic screwed
everything up we're
in year one i feel like we're in year
one i feel like we're in year one
certainly in phase one
right exactly yeah of the new i call it
the multiverse saga and we have a lot
more to talk about but first big thank
you to athletic greens for sponsoring
this video if you are trying to be more
healthy if you're trying to support your
immune health if you're looking to have
more energy and you're tired of taking
all of those pills athletic greens is
for you i wanted to see what all of the
hype was about so i tried athletic
greens it gives you over 75 high quality
vitamins minerals adaptogens and
probiotics now this is lifestyle
friendly so you can take this whether
you're doing paleo keto vegan dairy-free
gluten-free you can still take this and
it's less than three dollars a day which
is pretty cheap considering you're
investing in your health and the best
part is it actually tastes pretty dang
good so if you're looking to get
healthier and toss out the pills and the
supplements athletic greens makes it
easy they're going to give you a free
one year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and 5 free travel packs with
your first purchase all you have to do
is visit
athleticgreens.com
cosmic again that is athleticgreens.com
cosmic take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance i think patience
is like a big part people are getting
impatient and that is affecting their
attitude towards the shows right because
they go into a new show like miss marvel
and they're like okay where you know
tell me she's an inhuman right and
that's how i think so i'm like when is
it gonna happen but i try not to let it
affect my overall feelings for the show
like if she's not an inhuman
okay that's the route they decided to go
down right it shouldn't like
be such a detriment to the story and how
i feel about the show i want to judge it
based on what it is and i think that's
another big thing is again people are
judging it like it's movies remember we
used to have two three marvel movies a
year that was it now we have four marvel
movies a year and like five six disney
plus shorts and so much more so many
things chris we talked about this before
you brought up a good point
people didn't like everything about the
infinity saga oh absolutely not let's
talk about iron man three let's talk
about thor two let's talk about
you know people have complaints all the
time and now all of a sudden infinity
saga comes out or infinity war and game
come out and it's like this is the
greatest
thor still had problems iron man still
had problems you know the character
development had you know we didn't start
off with ragnarok we started off with
thor
the original and his character changed
and now people love it
it's such an interesting
short-term memory by choice
and i do it's like oh yeah the infinity
saga was just an absolute smack tens
across the board it's like well it
wasn't
right it just ended with a bang right
and since that's the last thing we got
people compare the all the new stuff to
that because that set the standard for
them well you and i even sorry have the
the awesome
responsibility of you walk out of thor
love and thunder coming out real soon
guys get excited
and what do they ask you
how does it compare to avengers end game
right yeah how does it compare to
avengers infinity war it's like
reflecting right now that's not what
it's like it's like asking
in your top five movies or whatever you
know yeah it's like asking a high school
soccer team to go up against a
professional soccer team and then how
did they do it's like they're not
they're not comparable and everybody
always wants to compare them yeah it's
like you need to compare thor to
iron man 3
right like yeah
and you can't compare the disney plushes
they're new they're untouched right it's
it's different space
right
so i think people
that's the that's a big problem is
people compare the disney plush shows
and you watch something like miss marvel
which is fun and visually a cool show
and a lot of people are really enjoying
it especially you know like the
pakistani
uh like viewers uh the indian viewers
like a lot of people are really enjoying
this and a lot of you know people who
aren't of those you know cultures are
still really enjoying it as well like i
enjoy it it's a good show it's not the
greatest thing ever to me right this is
my personal opinion it's not like like i
like moon knight a lot more than i like
miss marvel i like logie a lot lot more
but i like it more than i think i like
hakkai
you know what i mean like it just kind
of depends on your taste but
you can't compare them to the to the
movies but if we look at
phase four and five because a lot of
people are
i think fail to realize we know most of
phase five already yeah if marvel sticks
true to what they said they said thor
love and thunder is the last phase four
project right so this they've announced
a lot right so we have we've had let's
just
talk about these movies and shows that
we've had already black widow shang chi
eternals spider-man knowing home
multiverse of madness thor love and
thunder one division falcon winter
soldier loki what if miss marvel hawkeye
moon knight that's what we've got so far
and yeah black widow wasn't the best
thing ever they did it way too late yeah
that was the issue of timing more than
quality yeah there were some cgi
problems i mean no i personally don't i
don't think spider-man far from home is
phase four and not phase three and
continuity arrows or guys are no way
home far from home
from home happens post blip
but it's part of phase three
it's yeah it's infinity saga yeah um
so i don't can i i like black widow
should have been in the infinity saga
too it should have been between infinity
war and in game but shang chi i i
thought that was amazing i'm literally
quoted in marvel's trailer
and i mean it yeah and you know what
it's a favorite of a lot of people i
mean how many little kids came out and
said chunk cheese their new favorite
hero a ton right
and
i just i haven't really heard much about
like really anything bad about shanghai
everybody really loves that movie
eternals that's divided in half it was a
grand movie it was a bit it was
different too right i think the problem
with the eternals was they they made it
out to be something that it wasn't
because they kept talking about how the
mcu is going to change forever
and so we were like oh they're going to
show the x-men being created and we're
going to show all this and then they
like change the origin of the eternals
they're like sentient robots and stuff
now so it's like okay they kind of threw
some stuff off there but it was a big
movie it was a good movie it just wasn't
the greatest thing ever spider-man no
way home i loved it i mean a lot of
people loved it yeah i think the
majority of people loved it obviously
with the cameos and everything i felt
the cameos were done in a way that
wasn't just fanfare
fan service i thought it was amazing
multiverse of madness is actually
getting some split reviews i thought a
lot of people are gonna really really
like it um
but even now as i think about it i'm
like
i might not have liked it as much as i
thought i did well you said it when we
walked out of the the premiere the first
time around and we've watched it several
times since but it wasn't as
multiverse of madness it wasn't what i
thought it was going to be and i think
that was again the problem the same
problem with the eternals they made it
out to be something multiverse of
madness when it was really kind of just
about
strange wanda of madness yeah
you know because it was like you had the
universe where america javas came from
and defended strange then you have our
main universe then you have um
the eight one three universe and then
you have
whatever the sinister strangest universe
is what and they barely was left of it
yeah right and it's like okay we thought
it was gonna be so much but that was
gonna be like every universe you go to
you see a cameo and blah blah blah blah
i mean it's called multiverse of madness
like
so i think again expectations which is
uh something we'll talk about here well
i was just about to say to that point
though that's kind of the purpose of
this conversation here is was that
marvel's fault
right or is that the fan's fault because
here we are the multiverse of madness
was the introduction to the multiverse
you and i both believe the multiverse is
here to stay we're in the multiverse
saga right so multiverse of madness
kicks off you know here's the multiverse
here's the word incursion look at some
different characters look at them
interact
were we sitting there expecting to see
the entire multiverse storyline play out
in one movie and then get disappointed
when it doesn't happen or did marvel
make a bad movie
i think i think it was a combination of
expectations and
um
i don't know what to call this but i
think marvel led us to believe is going
to be a little bit bigger than it was
marketing
right the marketing was uh i mean
literally the title is multiverse well
that's true that's true and it wasn't
it wasn't
i don't think it was like the multiverse
of madness it was like a few universes
mm-hmm and there's a multiverse
because i thought like everything was
gonna get thrown in like off its course
and like incursions were like gonna
happen and we're gonna see all this
happening but really what it is is
they're going to different universes and
and the scarlet witch is chasing them
right so the only true madness that
happens out of their universe is when
they travel through the multiverse a bit
and then one that kills the spoiler
that's too late
you haven't seen it or seen online
that's on you it's on disney plus yeah
but but but for love and thunder i think
a lot of people are really going to love
especially if you love ragnarok if you
didn't like ragnarok at all not gonna
lie you're probably not gonna like it
yeah yeah they definitely leaned into
the ragnarok
right yeah they they they went further
and i think it's freaking a home run i
love that oh man let's but the movie is
coming up
well let's talk about disney push first
on division was fantastic
it's a lot of people's favorite
loki was my favorite fantastic dub and
that had a lot of big uh like
implications for the mcu right kang
introduced king that's like insane
um what ifs i hated what if
a lot of people who loved we were
talking about this during miss marvel
episode four after party and a lot of
people loved it
right which i was kind of like good for
you wow yeah wow yeah i'm really happy
you all loved it i'm glad you have
happened it was not for warren
i freaking hated it um
i enjoyed falcon in the winter soldier
i didn't enjoy how it ended
um and i think that's the problem a lot
of people have it have with it um but i
enjoyed hawkeye i thought it was fun
it was cool about you know king ping and
everything
echo i thought it was really cool how
can i exceed the expectations
yeah and miss marvel's doing i think
okay so far
um
and moon knight crushed it i mean that
was fantastic so overall
i think we have more hits than misses
for sure
right now you know shang chi spider-man
uh how you feel multiverse and madness
under uh one division loki you know uh
and this list is different for everybody
right well you could take a second to
compare those releases of the first
phase of the new era
to the first movies that came out in the
infinity saga so how does that compare
to
this film how does shangchi's origin
story compare to captain america's
that's the comparison that we're not
making i like i
right and i think
i think they compare i agree especially
yeah
moon knight these are all origin stories
so so is iron man captain america thor
how did those actually compare to the
original origin stories because these
are the heroes of the future of phase
five six seven eight nine
right and i think another one thing we
definitely have to talk about is the
connectivity because a lot of people are
complaining that there's a lack of
connectivity
and yes there was connectivity in the
beginning
but
there weren't like cameos and stuff like
i mean we like we'd see like captain
america shield right
like things like that right right little
things like that so it wasn't like over
the top crazy and it's like oh yeah
howard starks and captain america right
so it's like okay there's your
connection there
but uh they weren't crazy big like this
i think the biggest thing was the post
credit scenes really teased thanos
coming the post credit scenes have been
kind of late right
yeah and i could agree with that like oh
my gosh like no offense to bruce
campbell but like why did we have that
well they took something out and put
something there and it was
other bruce campbell stuff out that was
still dumb yeah i was like i'm coming
for you doctor stranger you'll pay
whatever it was like yeah still don't
start
yeah i will say that the thor love and
thunder post credits are cool yeah
depending on what they mean for the
future for sure
well one really means something oh maybe
oh yeah people are gonna love that one
and the other one even if it doesn't
mean anything it was nice yeah right it
was nice i thought it was it's not a
waste
right you can't i don't think you can
watch it and say well that's nothing
nothing is worse i don't care what
anybody says than the hawkeye post
credits
which one was that the the stage
cap rogers
oh my gosh with ant-man at the battle of
new york oh god
so fast you can't beat that that was the
worst yeah um but i think the biggest
thing to think about here is
it's a building phase again yeah right
we're literally introducing new
characters like
sean chi introduced new characters
eternal new characters
miss marvel yeah moon knight miss marvel
um hawkeye introduced a new character
loki introduced new characters right so
did one of vision technically
with akatha and because there's going to
be aggie hartness show coming so you
know
it's a combination of old characters
because you can't just get rid of all
the new characters and do a complete
wipe or all the old characters do
complete wipe but now we have the new
characters coming in as well and they're
origin stories right and i actually if
you think about it
no never mind i was going to say it's
actually the old character shows and
movies that people are okay with mm-hmm
but that's not something no no no no
yeah
chiang chi is amazing
i thought that turtles was pretty good
what's funny is i don't understand how
people can hate eternals but like dune
because they were like the same movie i
thought they were like the same for the
same structure yeah in a lot of ways it
was true
the storytelling was the same yeah i
agree which is why i like both because i
liked that and that's fine if you don't
i actually didn't like dune
when i say that
i didn't hate dune but i i think i
talked about expectations i think i
expected more right
and that's and that's a big thing that i
think the
fan base will have to take the
responsibility of and and i might go off
i do not represent warren with these
words but
i can't stand the star wars fan base
they are so whiny and picky in
particular they can't enjoy anything
like spoiler alert luke and leia aren't
gonna die in obi-wan kenobi like we know
this like enjoy your freaking show
and i don't want marvel to become like
that where they're sitting there
thinking they know more than the people
who wrote the freaking stuff
it's like we have a responsibility as
influencers in
a
community to maybe say guys
just relax it's coming it's it's the it
comes back to the patience thing
the hard part um
right because it's all new like we're
still i still think we're in the first
year phase four right so
really what we need to do
is
each thing you watch watch it for what
it is
just watch it for what it is and and
judge it
how much you like it based off of what
it is we the comparison game like
comparison is the thief of joy yeah that
applies to movies and grace too right it
really does so be in the moment be
present watch the shows watch the movies
and watch them for what they are like
thor love and thunder watch it for what
it is do not expect
like crazy
things that like don't expect i don't
want to say anything we have black
panther 2
which you have to imagine they took a
lot of care with no i would be shocked
if it was that's a delicate situation
right i really would captain marvel 2
the marvels
i don't know i really don't know
i i really don't know
uh guardians three how could that be bad
there won't be
blade that's gotta be killer ant-man in
the water condominium king i mean
how could that be bad paul rudd you know
uh fantastic four
do you like that's
kevin feige's pride and joy deadpool
deadpool yeah three though
right and then
she-hulk's coming up and if the rumors
are true might see the fantastic four
some big stuff
daredevil
secret invasion you know that's gonna be
big um
i am group should be fun the holiday
special for guardians should be fun the
only ones i don't really know about are
iron heart and armor wars not sure what
direction they're gonna take it but i
mean armor wars is about iron man
technology so it's got to be somewhat
cool yeah
that'd be somewhat cool so i think the
future is bright and kevin feige said
that it's all about to connect we're all
about to figure it out so hopefully uh
san diego comic con d23 that's where it
all
i don't think you just mean
announcements are coming just meant
announcements are coming i think he was
talking about like we'll see in shows
and movies as well like we'll see it
connect and uh
yeah i think
i don't think marvel's blowing it to
answer the question i don't think
marvel's blown it i don't think
everything that they release is going to
be a 10
but that's just how anything is yeah
it's not always going to be a 10 out of
10. everything's not going to be in game
at infinity war so expectations and
patience i think are the key to kind of
enjoying this phase and maybe phase five
and before everything starts to get
really really big and it's going to come
and it's going to be awesome and then
we'll get to some of these 10 projects
like avengers 5 and right secret i mean
i thought something was
well right yeah absolutely and not
everybody's gonna like every character
and every story that comes out so pick
and choose your favorite heroes and then
when they all do pancake together in a
super marvel cinematic universe way we
can freak out and have fun yeah i think
it'll pay off more in the end that would
take so much time i agree you i really
do i think justice league
yeah oh gosh that's all you need to say
justice league right exactly how they
did it yeah no we're taking so much time
introducing these characters
taking the time to introduce the
characters taking the time to build
everything up and and bring together
i'm not worried
i'm really not
and i think they've done a good job with
phase four so far but what do you think
let us know in the comments down below
smash the like button
could we be the youtuber from what like
three years ago that's how people work
no but
truly let us know what you think we want
to know this is why we made
this is why we discussed this in this
episode because a lot of people were
talking about it so we thought we would
address it give our thoughts on it so
let us know what you think down below if
you're new to my channel subscribe for
more videos like this and other
informational videos chris subscribe to
him over at cosmic culture we'll link
that and we'll put handles like here and
stuff uh and yeah let us know your
thoughts and we'll catch you next time
woof